[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
but i always like making people laugh
like i used to do a similar thing when i
was a child at the lunch table we'd get
some kids who were minnows or a couple
might have been minnows and a couple
kids that were well you know when we get
there and sit i'm gonna make them drink
milk and then tell jokes and do stuff
and to tell one of us just blew milk out
of their face you know
and if you get some straight up just
couple minnows boys i'm straight up saw
it off humans
you get them dude you get them straight
up blow leche out there dumb dude
[Laughter]
that's america right there
you know what i'm saying
and that's when i knew i was like oh i
got some kind of a gift here you know
i almost blew the throat out of this one
boy
almost through the this just almost blew
the throat out of this
this one boy named tot t-o-t with his
name
kind of a bad name too to be mentally
challenged
but also easy for him to spell and
i'm not joking that's what his father
said and um easy for him to spell
backward and forward same name todd
so oh that's true man was this guy's
real his name was todd
why are you still laughing at him
it's just a funny sounding name that's
all i'm saying you're right yeah it was
pretty funny i guess
sometimes he would just say t.o.t was
his name but i knew it was tot yeah he
would try to spell it out and you know
like he was tricking me in that town
they'll scout you out when you're like a
little
like the high school coach will go to
the middle schools and and like
you know size you up like they'll like
they're like kind of like
they just scout you out they're like oh
yeah he's gonna be does it feel illegal
is it dirty over there or is it just
kind of what do you what do you mean by
that i mean it just sounds like
i mean it's crazy like a lot of these
you know where is powei first of all
exactly where is it
it's more inland like escondido yeah
it's not like oh i thought it was in
damn
laotian or something i think you guys
were lay ocean
i'm thinking like this island or
something oh man what's up [ __ ]
san diego oh jesus
slowly well dude just get out of town
you act like some guys coming down from
the [ __ ] mountain no coming down from
the volcano and picking you guys out off
the branches man
jesus no it's uh it's a place in san
diego oh it's a town in seattle we'll
[ __ ] get it together yeah yeah i
don't know no i had it look the first
audition i ever had in town i remember
her being so scared i couldn't even open
my mouth in an audition room
what was that for
i don't remember not even something big
but it was at e it was at the e network
and i remember i could not even open my
mouth and i was like can you guys open
the window or something and like yeah
the windows don't open up here we're
like on the 26th floor of some building
yeah like the windows don't open up here
and i'm thinking what kind of
shitty company doesn't let you kill
yourself if you want to
so did you do like the open
mic circuit in l.a yeah i started doing
open mics here like at marty's or where
like uh
meltdown and stuff no they had a place
over on the west side of town i lived i
was sleeping under a buddy of mine had a
bed and i was sleeping under his bed for
150 a month oh wow and sometimes even in
his bed sometimes
when he would be out of town or when he
would leave for work i'd climb up into
his bed dude and i've never been heavily
homosexual but i will say this
that there's nothing really gayer than
getting into a man's warmth after he's
already left the room you know and
climbing up into his bed
i mean you don't even really know that
much
but still catching that hit off of his
temperature you know
it's true man
you go over to somebody's house dude you
don't know that much when they leave the
room and get the get get out of their
bed you get into their bed
that's something you never told them
that though make a man out of your fast
dude or it won't
you find out who's who pretty quick when
you're doing stuff like that yeah is
there a lot of any asians in your town
let me see
i remember seeing
the first asian i ever saw
well i saw some drawings
right
and we're definitely seeing a lot of
drawings when we're kids of asians
because they're easy to draw
so a lot of kids are draw asians right
after that
true story the next asian i ever saw the
closest real asian
was that picture in the guinness book of
world records when there's like an asian
like 17 asian kids on a bicycle remember
that one the famous yeah yeah
no that was just the first
i was like holy [ __ ]
look what they can do you know
and it made me like but it made us do
cool stuff on our bike and like see what
we can yeah
and then there was a rumor when i was
about 14 that there was an asian boy
there was a rumor there was an asian boy
about 17 miles away from us
and me and two of my buddies
one of them who had a
bad neck it fell out of pretty bad
you know that fifth appendage the neck
people don't think about it you gotta
strengthen it and his was
real lean barely hold his head up he
almost had a he almost had to
walk around like this and also hold his
head up with one of his arms
but he and i and another kid
uh
got together and decided we want to go
see this asian you know this ruiner
yeah yeah so we saved up money we cut
grass for about six weeks and saved up
money to get a taxi
just to see this guy yeah okay went to
slidell louisiana to go visit him
and you just went to his house no it was
the address that we got oh you you how
did you get this address dude you can
get information okay
okay and this is back before the
internet too oh this one you'd ask
around yeah and then guess a little
and we uh we went to see him and tried
to go see him but it was just a uh
it was a
chinese food restaurant oh
he's a chinese guy it wasn't real
chinese person it was just i think some
kind of white people in hats and it was
like uh
i don't know it might have been like a
mexican jewish guy running it oh that's
weird but it wasn't any
no real asians
so it's just amazing so we went back man
it cost us about seventy dollars
and then i had some abandonment issues
actually when it came to asians for a
long time because of that and then the
kid named jason desport that showed up
when i was in junior high school
and people used to always people they
had this group at the time called whites
against mexicans and people would attack
him sometimes even though he wasn't
mexican because he was the closest thing
we had to a mexican he was asian
pretty much korean chinese japanese
he was kind of like what does it happen
when you would see like on some of the
posters with the rosy cheeks kind of
jesus i like wearing a diaper like
sitting in a tub
no man
george help me out man what do you mean
george george help me out
dude you can
phone a freaking icelandic guy
lonnie
what's he talking about what's the
happiest of the eight i mean this kid
was probably happy kind of same skin
tone as ilani
yes he could have been filipino he was a
beautiful guy yeah the only the only
thing i've even seen in the past
probably 15 years was the incredibles
have you seen that no
it's about like a cartoon family that
gets um
gets uh
they kind of fight amongst themselves
but then they also fight crime okay cool
yeah
that's the only one
new blade running
i never saw any blade runner
any fast and furious know that
oh i tried to see s
saw
train oregon
secrets of the
ee
what is it
asian
killers on the train what does that
orient express
okay you know it murders on the iron
express piece of [ __ ] if you haven't
seen that yet how about this i'd rather
spend 30 bucks take an amtrak see real
crime
hell yeah way better dude take your son
daughter
you know side piece whatever on a 40
amtrak ride you know two cities down two
cities back half the afternoon beautiful
scenery
sit in the club car way better crime
probably buy some jewelry off of
somebody who's a mason
and uh and
much better but do you you never bought
them all right did you bomb it all in
the beginning yeah i've definitely
bombed a few times yeah you know i
bombed the other night somewhere
still
yeah it was just sometimes it's a weird
crowd sometimes it's
you know it could be a strain sometimes
during the year there's just a weird
night or two where everybody doesn't
everybody doesn't do well yeah i i hope
i try i try to do what i try to do try
to do stand up yeah
i opened up for bob at the tempe improv
and it was it was a packed crowd yeah
and i had uh because i was hitting mics
and everything yeah but i did this
cowboy wrap thing it wasn't even a bit
it was just me i don't know you know
doing the thing and and i bombed
horrendously damn yeah it was painful
so they kicked me off the other shows
really so yeah well i knew something
wasn't right because i did my thing i
didn't engage the crowd and i just did
it and the emcee had to save me the mc
had to go hey anyway come on let's get
off the stage
and so i just remember i cuz uh you've
been to the tempi improv you have to
walk through the crowd to get to the
green room yes so i remember i remember
walking like i was just i like i thought
i did good and i was walking by the
crowd and they wouldn't even look at me
like
like that and i'm like and that that's
when i'm like oh
like a [ __ ] in the 70s
yeah
and so i was in the green room and my
brother goes uh i'm proud of you that
you went up
but uh yeah they we don't we're they
don't have time
yeah but he went he was trying to save
my right save you know right he was he
didn't want to
tell me that the manager went up to him
and said your brother's cut right he
just said uh yeah you could go home yeah
you just drive
back you could drive back damn
because there's two other shows yeah
yeah oh
yeah was that a bummer or not oh it was
painful yeah cause i heard i got it from
my mom too i guess my brother was
texting her when i because i went to del
taco
i wanted tacos so yeah i bought tacos
drive through and then i went home
and my mom knew i didn't do well oh so
she was getting on me like asking bob
the bits
no like what did you do and i'm like
yeah i was just doing a cowboy rap mom
that's not comedy you know
you don't know comedy
i went i stormed upstairs damn and then
my brother went in this is in gilbert
arizona yeah my mother
and so my brother went in later that
night into the room and he goes can i
talk to you and i go yeah what do you
want and he goes
uh
i just have a few suggestions man let me
help you right
and then i got really defensive at that
i know comedy man i was like just really
like stubborn you know damn dude that's
like a weird like a yeah it was just
weird man i it was painful and that was
one of the last times i think i did it
yeah it seems like a weird foreign kind
of eminem
yeah man if it was asian that would have
been a good one yeah that would have
been real good yeah i could write my own
rams balls
valenzuela was our dad's name richie
i can draw the cartoons you know
okay so this is a maltese yeah were they
from malta obviously
but the thing is is that if they say
you're in our town an animal would just
go by
like a dog could be could be something
else
tall we had some tall
i don't know what they were came but
came by once um what else do we have
um
animals
livestock cats cats i grew up in the
near a hamster and guinea pig breeding
area
tons of those sometimes getting out when
they got out you'd see you know 700
[ __ ] guinea pig go by yeah you know
it's beautiful if you've never seen it
um but yeah
chimpanzees a lot of chimpanzees there
was monkeys no i was the little guy i
was a nine like a 103 pounder really
yeah yeah damn that was a little guy
yeah do you feel smaller you feel how do
you feel on the inside
what do you mean by that what do you
mean by that like whatever i mean i'm
just like a regular height you know i'm
like six foot tall
but you are probably what how do you
five four five six yeah i'm like
yeah five four five i'm a buck thirty
five buck forty if that when you get up
out of bed is it is it like it seems
like you get out of there really quick
i can um i'm kind of like my brother
cause we like rely we used to get in the
frigerator can't you if you wanted if
you took the shelves out i probably
could if i like that's crunched up yeah
yeah like i'm just trying to think of
fun things you like seemed like you
could probably do if you were just kind
of a more regular height you know or
just like your unique height you know
yeah like not in a bad way i'm just like
there's some things if i look at a place
i'm like oh i can't get under that or i
can't do this you know how tall are you
jump on that person's back or anything
yeah like you seem like you could be
more fun probably well like what do you
mean by that like i think people look at
you and like oh this guy's probably more
fun yeah maybe if they had a more fun
contest and you had a hundred people
who's more fun
i bet i've got 80 of them
yeah
[Music]
way i know
[Music]